at least i have to get cigarettes and
[ __ ]
nice
uh we got victor martinez
junior
garage mike comedy on instagram
we got ron martin who was recently on
kill tony and uh we have similar glasses
chris tan
you
tommy wish house
uh so what do you guys think about kyle
writing house
i think he's a stand-up guy man you know
i don't know it
seems like he got off the justice system
work more like a lay down and shoot guys
lucky he's not dropping soap right now i
heard he's a distant nephew of uh
derek shelvin oh yeah
that's just yeah
he's a good shot right he didn't mess up
did he miss
he's shot he's a good looking guy too
man
very sharp he didn't belong coming gay
right out the gate for the shooters man
he's probably getting way more [ __ ] now
i'll tell you that
all the trailer parks
rednecks
no it's cnn [ __ ] dude
fox news
so
what do we do here what are we doing why
are we here
i don't know man it's hard to explain
dude
like i could be out cheating right now
my baby mama thinks i'm like it's like
how the [ __ ]
can we have more dudes in here
hey you're not having fun at this orgy
the sausage party he's not [ __ ] with
women no he's doing a podcast with
twelve dudes at least three more seasons
i i also was attempting to get laid
tonight but i'm fine with [ __ ] around
here
hopefully uh you can be more authentic
here instead of pretending to be someone
you're not
all right god's honest truth this is a
circumcision party right here
hey [ __ ] you
i'm not trying to lose half a centimeter
right now i'm taking everything
or something
dude your laughs have laughs
um is there any way to get uh
swiggy in frame
get over here there's plenty of space on
the
i think someone's butt cheeks gotta go
here
we gotta go there
now we got swiggy in frame and you're
out of breath all right
hey maybe uh
all of you guys scoot this way a little
bit more not not that way you gotta
you gotta be in frame too
i like how logan is just like i'm not
even gonna try to get in
thank you a few days ago and like amy oh
came over and i just like this is boring
i was on william montgomery's podcast
and it was way more fun i was like all
right
she was podcast shaming you yeah she was
i was just doing it off of a cell phone
just like why i got it
dude i just realized it's sitting on a
garbage can
that took
uh
that i'm probably somewhat autistic and
uh
you know keep scooting or
am i in why why do i need schools
to be close to people oh my god
all right michael guys can you just
please
one of a kind scoot over where you're
like forward
am i out of frame though like that's
what i why don't you look at the frame
and figure it out for yourself why can't
you help me i'm not helping you by
telling you to scoot over um
victor you can stand right
here yeah you might want to go around
the bathroom
this is the most fun game of musical
podcast i'm ever going to play
this away
is this building like transform into
your van or something or just like
this is it the van transforms
[Laughter]
like the worst episode of transformers
ever
maybe we invited too many people
yeah we'll just see what the
live chat says
swing game live chat jesus
killer queef hans
get over isaac cappy
who's isaac cappy
oh he oh i know who isaac happy is isaac
happy is an uh actually he looks like me
he's a
he's a like a little known marvel actor
who got super into q and on and then
jumped off a bridge
in l.a and died
uh and there's a whole bunch of
conspiracy theories around him
there you go little isaac happy trivia
for him who is isaac in here him
no no no no i'm michael
that's not what i meant i just look like
him i'm actually not on that you look
like him and you also knew who the [ __ ]
he is so you have to
why don't you uh use this mic
uh okay
hey i think you just got promoted
michael yeah look at that i mean it's
got like 12 buttons
don't touch any of those
christmas michael we got some hands i'm
just trying my best always it's not good
enough yeah i know i'm knocking over
glasses but i'm like
i don't know
so making moments out here what do you
guys think about um
the mic tonight we just did a kimchi mic
started off
it was fun dane lost his [ __ ] we got to
see his uh his flab i didn't expect that
else i gotta see dane's belly
move on stage [ __ ] yeah i missed that
i refer to the mic as the fermented
cabbage mike
is kimchi korean
china's trying to take credit for it
right
they're calling it something else what's
the difference
uh
it's uh it's just a different name are
you serious
yeah didn't try to invent spaghetti i
heard like marker noodles
[Laughter]
china's trying to get rid of my country
taiwan what do you guys feel about that
you are china
[Laughter]
just because i look doesn't mean i am
sorry
do you support the us military
when they [ __ ] get rid of china from
taiwan yeah
that's like some koreans too they really
like the us military because they keep
north korea at bay something like that
dude you can't laugh in north korea
yeah all right
if swiggy was in north korea he would be
shot
we're having too much fun
this [ __ ] is missing the point
mr pimp is mr peter you got 12 canadian
cents per artist how many people
oh man who's coming out rich now boys
who's coming out real quick
right now
[Laughter]
i'm so scared to be sitting in front of
you i can hear the saliva
i think i'd be doing that when i'm
cutting meat at my work terry black's
looking like oh
that's the secret sauce huh
but if you come through my work and
mention during the swiggy army you'll
get a military discount for sure all
right i've done it once a few people and
the manager noticed it and then he
thought it was funny so i just kept
doing it like it's legit
started because like the military
discount it's kind of like the kiss army
but probably not as cool the kiss sucks
yeah
sorry do we have to go to boot camp to
get in how do we no man
gene simmons went to my jewish
sleep-away camp
he did
are there two jews here
i mean i'm don't look at me what are you
doing what no i'm just saying really
you look jewish
i didn't i wasn't paying attention
i'm not a very religious person though i
don't like
you like do religious stuff but like i
was raised i guess jewish you know
there's a lot of jews in the open mice
here i've noticed no there's only like
eight jews in austin
are you guys zionists
when i'm around you i don't even know
i thought you were just a misogynist i
thought you were a misogynist
yeah i am but that's not military
[Laughter]
it's just pure logic how many flat
earthers are at the table
i know that dude who's the flat earther
i'm getting like arguments with them
we'll look for the people who aren't
back constantly moving upward
that's like new physics like can you
argue with it it's like i don't agree
with it but can i argue with that i'm
not sure
howdy
right at my face let's go
that was that's not what we're trying to
do right we're trying to share it right
yeah all right fair enough
now feel free to speak and
don't feel self-conscious at all about
it
go ahead
are you assuming i'm a flat earther by
just putting in my face yeah
and go
yeah sure i'll be a flattered 13. i mean
you're from india they have a lot of
mountains there it's very mountainous
it's hard to be a flat earther when you
see me if there's a flat earth you think
there'd be like a picture of like the
edge or something new
are flat earthers more into edging
i'll just talk about flat earth or is it
because there's so many ages here and we
have flat chests
chests oh you are women
they look at us and they're like their
women have no breasts
why don't they just like look at our
faces and be like look at these
pan-faced gooks that's probably what the
earth is shaped like is there a fat
flat face
i heard this face
[ __ ] i heard this theory recently uh
about flat earthers right so they they
think they're like right if it's a flat
earth does that mean that on the other
side of the flat earth there are
dinosaurs burying their babies and then
we're digging them up and finding them
you know what i mean
is that how fossils are found is that
are they finding our
grandmothers and grandfathers buried too
and like what the [ __ ] is this dude
[Laughter]
um no
short i mean if you short for him bored
a hole through the earth and there was
like no lava and you like jumped into it
would you like fall out the other end or
just like get stuck in the middle
i saw that i was having so much trouble
visualizing it
what we're saying here is that we are
definitely archaeologists
we are definitely archaeologists
we're professionals absolutely one
hundred percent
sweetie i'm gonna think about that for
20 days that's a crazy thing you just
said that's [ __ ] crazy it's like a
pendulum
so apparently you could fit the
was it the whole world
don't give uh
attention to the most annoying people
for sure
room full of math geniuses and bad
drivers is all i see
i'm even in the car right now
it's probably accurate
that guy sounds like crumb from
yeah that's a dumb one
what's that uh real monsters maybe just
kind of rhymed i think it was he's the
dude that holds up oh real monsters
what the [ __ ] is old school nickelodeon
he finished his he didn't finish the
sentence like i know crumb right the guy
he's the guy that's what i'm saying yeah
but his sentence didn't make any [ __ ]
sense he said
he got to make out with
yeah they went to the ball together yeah
oh yeah i remember now yeah he was like
the quidditch star wars you can turn
into a shark for some reason did harry
potter did you know that uh oh yeah
that's actually a copyright infringement
of larry potter which came out first in
the 80s and there's like muggles and
stuff like that was it also written by
jk rowling no jk rowling stole it it
came out in the 80s before jk rowling's
book it's like very similar story larry
yeah
it's like a
redneck
yeah oh yeah the book was written on
paper towels instead of like copies it's
an actual but it's a kid's book that
it's meant for like little kids whereas
i think harry potter is known for like
young adults like teenagers but it's
like it's still got like similar it's
about wizards and there's like muggles
they call muggles like the humans like
it's slightly parallel thank you similar
maybe they're right it's maybe it's like
uh
maybe it's like the spice girls there's
harry potter there's scary potter
there's sport potter it's morty potter
that's like the [ __ ] redneck version
of harry potter it's like they except
some actual magic it's just [ __ ]
technology like oh [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
calculator they think it's like the most
[ __ ] magical thing or some [ __ ]
i don't know
it's a great universe great world
building and it's all about friendship
harry potter
is the universe flat if the earth is
flat
some could say
who would be a flat earther in harry
potter was that who would be a flat
earther in harry potter besides hagrid
yes this is the larry what would it be
like the jerseys or some [ __ ]
i would say it would be the end of the
harry potter
long bottoms
it is for like younger kids
oh god larry looks pretty chewy actually
i'm murdering right now dude
[Laughter]
okay who hasn't said anything you guys
should do a podcast now
victor
ron and tim washington shout out to the
commenters y'all should like send us
food or something you know
dude it's like well it's like pressed
processed pink meat and then they just
lather it with
barbecue sauce so it looks like
nah it is
chicken nuggets are so good
they are you can get a 20 piece for five
have any of y'all ever tried the the
sichuan sauce that they mentioned in
rick and morty
no i remember hearing about it yeah
well they have like a specialized like
rick and morty yeah yeah i i think i i
don't know if it was a joker i i think
it actually existed after mulan came out
oh [ __ ] really yeah i want to try
anybody confirm
i think i remember it existing when they
were stabbing people for those popeye
sandwiches i was there for that
how many people did you kill
ah you weren't there for that then dude
that was around i went to the same one
where they they got stabbed how many did
you kill i ate two of those popeyes
did you hear someone got stabbed there
and you're just like that's the one i'm
done
they got that
y'all remember the double down at kfc
yeah it was like the buns were just more
cheap yeah it was chicken sandwiching a
beef patty i think yeah yeah that was
amazing yeah that was a different time a
more hopeful time back on those kentucky
fried chicken not kfc
do you really want kfc right now it
looks like you're in like this oh no no
i'm just always in a dream
kfc is part of it they're coming out
with a chicken sandwich trying to
compete with popeyes what are your
thoughts they've been doing that for a
while haven't you yeah but like no one's
talked about it now they're trying to
rebrand do you think it's a competition
or it's not even kentucky fried anymore
it's called kitchen fries
oh yeah this is because sometimes
or something i know they got the aunt
jemima i'm pretty sure kentucky has
kitchens i was talking to this black
chick i worked with and i asked her
about it and she was like mine was my
[ __ ]
they cancelled that [ __ ] i'm gonna tell
you no one canceled it
the [ __ ] company was like let's the
[ __ ] company was like let's not be
racist anymore all right did you say
let's not be racist i say she was king
he's out of a job you guys are just
paranoid and uh resisting progress
what did they rename it does anybody
know
you don't even know hunt you were racist
dude it's just like yeah i don't know
they're pretty aware because you look at
wendy's that's like a karen they didn't
change them a habit of tradition now is
aunt jemima for life man you should have
tracked down jeremiah's grandkids and
gave him reparations that's where we
started
that's jamal and jessica's yeah
jessica that's the whitest thing
no it's like jokwanda or some [ __ ] you
know
the mascara
on the ground talk about his last bang
please sir
do it
hey man i was new to austin i was just
taking what i could get
but if you really want to know um i
still have a few nightmares
trying to trying to like get whatever
that was like up out of the way you know
the flaps yeah man it was
there was a lot of them bro there was a
lot there was a lot of them but there
were no pairs and layers of fupa it was
everywhere it was pretty pretty big
yeah there you go okay
that's called uh that's called a
testicle you were
did she did she get on top
yeah
yeah yeah sorry
it sounds like she's hurting
you sound like your hips hurt i'm okay
i'm okay
it sounds like she's on the top bottom
inside
yeah
yeah no it's a modified top it's fine
i still get a round okay all right
it almost sounds like you cramped as you
talked about her
yeah i know dude yeah it's uh it's
haunting a little bit yeah that was that
was a lot literally she dominican no not
just uh just uh why chris just a big old
white girl what what where did that come
from
i i think about lizzo and then i kind of
associate them together is lizzo
dominican she's like
poor i thought she's puerto rican
i thought she was puerto rican one thing
yeah she's a mix she's she's a husky
she's a little mutt oh and that and that
vaguely reminds you of dominicans am i
correct is that husky
i think so yeah you got it
so i think what everyone wants to know
chris is did you pay or not
why would you pay ron oh no well you
know you always pay i think uh you know
six seven beers i forget you know yeah
yeah it was about
tolerance
oh my god
i'll call
this [ __ ] snored so loud i should have
recorded it it would have been gold
right now her her cheek was making this
uh like like farting sound as it flapped
it was
rising dude i was like what the [ __ ] am
i listening to
and then like all these guttural noises
from inside of her it was bizarre why
didn't you just leave or was she at your
house
so uh
my truck was in the shop and i ubered
all the way there
and i was looking at the uber prices and
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'll chill you know
i gotta wait until 8 a.m before i can
pick my truck up i'm stuck here yeah and
i live in a trailer man it's so nice to
be in a place where i can like raise my
hands
outside
nice big porcelain toilet you know
i enjoyed her house looked through the
fridge a bit
i could tell she was coming you know you
could hear that [ __ ] thing rattling
it's not the whole [ __ ] body
it's like jurassic park you see the
ripple in the water
oh yeah there were ripples for sure
man
that's unfortunate but did you uh enjoy
it did you come or oh [ __ ] yeah over and
over they can't get enough yeah it was
the best yeah did you come yeah yeah
so am i the only one getting laid what's
going on
never had sex all right
i almost banged a white chick for my
first time last night but never happened
oh
oh did you get wrong i only got this
black guy
huh yes he did [ __ ]
[ __ ] that always happened she was hot
too she was hot i was there for their
wedding
is up on other people hans hey other
people you met on other people yeah
we're the first guests damn right they
did they met on other people
i was a hot new show in austin texas
every sunday at creek and cave
6 pm watch it live
saw a picture of you it was a blind date
and then [ __ ] we had a second date um
yesterday and oh she's gonna watch this
too she should be like you dirty dog
what'd you do on the second date what'd
you do
you won the segway tour
[Laughter]
excuse me uh please
lower your
boners it's not safe
that's a teepee
you think i'm sexy now wait till i'm
wearing a helmet on a segway
in your face
and your story other asian
uh i just moved here last time i had sex
the real answer is
with my ex
of four years so there you go
nothing fun right now do you have like a
fetish is there something that you
always need to make each other i'm
getting him late he's coming on your
show next
yes cool yeah he's still settling in
yeah
he doesn't want to get laid he doesn't
want it he doesn't need it
yeah
he's too traumatized i just need curry
what happened no he needs to he needs a
big gal man you give him a call hey big
one yeah
hey hey i'm going to give her yeah
yeah i got my hands on yeah right
get that [ __ ] off my ass
all right rahul your lucky day brother
oh [ __ ] he's actually getting a picture
or is she a fan of kill tony no no
no that's the like the one girl i
haven't how did y'all meet i love how
he's pulling her picture up but it's on
his bumble account tinder i'm going to
check them both so she hasn't blocked
you yet that's good yeah
you never get rid of them you never
didn't did not unmatched
in the space move to tender now sorry
you got it wrong
before they unmatch you
say hello
say hello to your future there she is
she's a lot of fun
[Music]
would you rather sleep with her or would
you rather sleep oh my god you hooked up
with mimi meyer i'd rather sleep with my
ex again i knew that you want to do that
right
you want to sleep with you what's what's
up with you and your ex i feel like
there's something [ __ ] up going on
with you and your ex oh no this just
went from podcast to therapy session
well i mean there's nothing
like i think the toughest thing is that
there was nothing wrong it was just like
incompatibility like she wants
kids and
marriage and all that soon
and i just don't like you just want to
keep being a man [ __ ] is that what you
want to do pretty much yeah hey man and
you won't [ __ ] a fat chick
it looks like you broke up for nothing
this guy's got standards what a chump
now now are you assuming that you don't
want to [ __ ] a fat chick or
have you done it and then
been traumatized because then we can
start a group i've honestly
i've actually had
this is not why
but i have actually had
a ton of my friends
being like
really literal
like i have a friend who's like [ __ ]
five five and for some [ __ ] reason he
being like a
he bangs a chick he banged a chick one
time i wouldn't even call it a chick
he said he said he's not pro trans
[Laughter]
um
i don't know ellie's from his
description he he called her a ditto
like a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] pokemon
it's awesome then she could be anything
you want that's true perfect
is that how ditto is like a mcrib like
she like like transforms or whatever
yeah whatever you want man you can [ __ ]
a charizard you don't want that ditto is
a good idea just like hold it into
whatever the [ __ ] you want you know
i've been [ __ ] a lot of
milfs and cougars lately how's that
going yeah it's fun the second i turned
25 a lot more uh
gals with kids come up to me
cause you see that was what i was into
yeah and then when you this was my name
is your ex
she's like five or six years older than
me hell yeah dude yeah you're
independent
huh no she doesn't have kids i'm not
into that in and out of girls i'm saying
like like i guess like girls who are
older
or whatever yeah
i actually lost my virginity to [ __ ]
cougar how old was she she was like
late 40s and i was 21. 20. oh damn and
she had like a kiss she claimed to have
it was like how long did you last
i didn't i got like i was [ __ ]
nervous it was my first time
so two pumps probably like the same no i
i just didn't even yeah oh no you put
all the condoms
yeah basically
well i was 21 and then she like
basically hinted that her her son was
around 21.
yikes
so are you the kid from story of pie
that [ __ ] the tiger in the book
is that what happened
yo did you talk to her son
no well so i'll tell you guys the whole
story actually so we're in vegas and um
i was like wait we me and my buddies
were waiting for like this limo to come
because it was supposed to take us to
like
five different like venues or some [ __ ]
and it was like a [ __ ] over an hour
late so i was like [ __ ] let me just
like talk to random people so i was like
i was just like i went up to this
[ __ ] i talked to some chicks and then
i went to this older woman that was just
sitting at the bar just drinking her
[ __ ] gin and tonic
and uh
i she was like just like focus on her
drink she wasn't even like turning to
talk to me i was just like [ __ ] yeah
i was gonna say a bunch of [ __ ]
and then i was like hey let's just like
let's go to this other like [ __ ]
like clubby room or whatever like behind
the [ __ ] bar i was like let's hang
out there and she's like
she was like [ __ ] irish in a butcher
of the accent but she was like
you have a condom or some [ __ ]
i was like i was like uh
yeah i do but it was just like so
[ __ ] out of nowhere and then she
basically suggested to like go to her
hotel which was
like in that or
got her room like her hotel room which
was in that same hotel
and then she like she was like oh yeah
stay like five steps beside me or some
[ __ ] she was like trying to be all
covered as she went into the [ __ ]
like passive security or whatever the
[ __ ] i feel like she was [ __ ] married
or some [ __ ] because yeah or
very professional
could be
she probably has like some dude that
she's with at the hotel he's caught up
in the workers to like see right it's
like dude who's like half or like a
third of that dude's age like hey that's
just how irish people have sex they are
very ashamed about it it's like
it's actually a beautiful ritual huh
they have uh that's their culture it's a
ceremony they have to drink all the
vodka forget about it
it's like downton abbey all the time for
them and then i [ __ ] you now so we go up
and then uh
we start she starts sucking me off and
then i get hard from that i put my
condom on and i didn't know this at the
time but like the [ __ ] normal like
trojan condoms we're two [ __ ] yeah i
years later i found out that [ __ ]
magnums work for me
like the [ __ ]
the regular trophies you have a big [ __ ]
what a humble that's why you wanted to
tell the story
much better
in this latex garden
i'm wondering if the girl's even real
so i put it on and then i mean
i thought we were talking about tiger
here i put it on my dick just instantly
went soft that's what happened yeah yeah
and then uh that's your penis being like
oh we're not gonna make a baby what's
the point yeah yeah
yeah i'm indian this
marriage and only for the purpose of
having kids that's about it
and that was it
no no so uh we like [ __ ] it was
really pathetic after that point we just
like dry humped a little bit
and then or i tried to like shift my
soft ass dick in there i was like i
gotta do this i was [ __ ] committed
yeah it didn't work
and then uh
when we i'll backtrack a little bit when
she like when we took off our clothes
she was like oh you're so hairy i was
like yeah yeah i was like i was like
yeah i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] charge
anderson hair all over yeah dude how are
you that hairy at 21 and i'm still
struggling to grow i don't know i don't
know
yeah i i mean
that's true well to be honest though i
did i basically went in like i got a
[ __ ] i went in like once does this
count
i went in once
i i can't total sex man yeah okay
the fact that a chick was willing to
have sex with you is pretty much all and
you saw her naked yeah
i mean seeing someone naked isn't the
same
in a trash can afterwards no but you got
the consent that's why i'll do that
afterwards well i got a [ __ ] i went
in
how did you have sex for the first time
well the first time i was having like a
party at my house and then [ __ ] uh of
course we're we're listening in the
chumbawamba like i get knocked down
i get knocked down and i get [ __ ]
again
i remember her friend came in as i was
banging her it was like my buddy's
sister and she saw me [ __ ] hers it
was kind of awkward on her told her to
tell her to roll up babe and after i
banged her there she totally threw up in
this trash can though they had like next
to my bed that i just loved it i was 20.
yeah she was 17 so
swiggy
i remember when i was 18 i had my own
apartment and like this chick was like a
runaway like these cops came in i guess
like she banged like someone on my
roommate's bed and
she like covered for him or something
because she was like 17 and the dude was
like in his 20s or something so she said
that i banged her and i was like 18.
they're trying to get me for like i
didn't even do it but they're trying to
get me on like some sex crime [ __ ] for
[ __ ] banging a 17 year old at 18.
like i didn't even do it everyone the
cops came in though i was like i'm still
a virgin though i couldn't have done
like oh yeah sure sure buddy
that charge got dropped though i never
got charged with there was like a
pending charge a little bit that's
pretty well talked about
is anyone here like drop acid or like
hell yeah
the best part of my story though is that
at the very end i disappointed her
basically and she was like all right i
have a friend who's coming and uh he's
black
i'm not even [ __ ] kidding i was and
she's like you should probably go he's
like a big black dude yeah and i was
like wow
i was like oh [ __ ] that in my head but
in hindsight i'm like why the [ __ ] was
she saying that [ __ ] i don't know i like
how the cops look that squiggy having
sex and they're like there has to have
been a crime here
there's no way this is legal within our
law
i also like how swingy started a story
was like i was 20 and she was 17. he's
like oh wait i was 18 and she was seven
two different stories the when i was 18
with the 17 i didn't actually have sex
yet when i was 20.
there's all sorts of sex studies
two different
but he didn't even do it right it's
still [ __ ] illegal
yeah like technically
yeah maybe i'm technically if we want to
get weird i think swaggy
are those what those tattoos are for to
remind you all the underage children you
slept with
bowser yeah
just like two years ago
in my life again bowser and the lion
all right who wants to sub it who wants
to
you know uh get subbed out
i'll tag out i'll take a little break
yeah i think my ass is done with this
trash can
you want to talk about [ __ ] come back
oh yeah get in this glory hole buddy
go go around the
around the bathroom and come through the
other side
walk around the flat earth
come back to us
so yeah i mean uh virginity is
very uh precious and beautiful and
it's good to have your first time be
with someone that you uh love and trust
and
you ever [ __ ] a prostitute
yeah yeah yeah so uh
yeah i went to a spa
right in seattle and like uh woodenville
or issaquah or something and uh it was
like an asian massage parlor and she was
like hey oh hello oh do you have your id
that's like why do you need my id for a
[ __ ] brother
what the [ __ ] is going on here yeah they
have a lot of them if they have like
some in philly where you're going and
like they don't even offer the massage
when you get in there you start [ __ ]
i was thinking what if a guy had like a
serious neck problem they want some
massages i want a [ __ ] sucky
[Laughter]
oh fine get it over with
so pat uh welcome to the podcast
i'm so happy to be here what did you uh
think about this podcast when you walked
in
uh a lot going on
yeah totally that's true
yeah do you think this is too many
people oh you're sure
it looks like you just came from [ __ ]
thank you
that's more of a accident than anything
but did he want to get in on the podcast
i could we could yeah i mean if he where
do you go let's just ask him if he wants
to get in just really a lot of pressure
right now
to do well on the podcast everyone's got
a microphone we've all been killing so
you guys know i know yeah sucking the
least it's been a lot of dead ends
should we play katan is it worth it or
should we talk more about ron martin
[ __ ] fat chicks
she already texted me saying i better
shave my legs and you know what that
means right yeah talk about it now is
that is that a step up or what han
let me see i saw the last oh my god it's
sarah she's hiding
she's lying on her stomach she's hiding
her flaps you don't know how many flaps
she has under that thing you know she's
a bartender and she texted me and she
said uh if you want to stop by tonight
i'll be the tall blonde what the [ __ ]
are you doing here bro belly bear okay
you came to play katan with us
[Applause]
the boys need me i got a board game
but yeah can we see your profile
let's do clerical logistical work first
picture i'm at machu picchu so are you
gonna show the are you gonna show the
camera yeah yeah
is that machu picchu he knows how to
hide
by yourself to show that you're not
clinging that's good
yeah yeah i got her to get out of the
frame right
right because you're just
going to match it by yourself
whatever this isn't good podcasting you
shouldn't have asked to see his profile
um
it's a good one
it works yeah
this is what you walked in 49 49 years
like
i can give you guys tips this is what
we're getting a neighborhood complaint
for us
your profile say you keep the crocs on
during sex or is it
are you in sport mode or are you in
[ __ ] yeah no i mean the sneakers the
ones that people were distracted by on
the kill tony show they kept [ __ ]
making fun of my sneakers i keep those
on man i need traction do you wear socks
yeah yeah that help the track yeah just
the little short socks i slip out of my
socks like i have tennis shoes yeah no
it's the socks are dangerous man yeah
they are
crosstalk i'd rather go shoes with no
socks or just socks
in bed
i think shoes like cleats with no socks
cleats no socks all day are you wearing
shoes right now oh you took your shoes
off okay
yeah the all the shoes are in the front
it's like a giant mess and then like
there's all we've all drove individually
so there's like 17 cars
yeah
all the parking spots are full what are
they doing at 3am
uh what the [ __ ] is sweetie
is that some sort of uh soft drink
there's a beer caught so
yeah american
uh
it i'm not sure i mean i'm sure it's
american-made or something for them it's
like i think it's like some local
brewery on there oh [ __ ] yeah
swiggy
and then you two can share the shirt oh
[ __ ] i forgot you got that one
sure
so so you're not the first swiggy so
it's a little bit like with with larry
and harry maybe yeah
larry potter is there g
john
john weasley
larry potter
so why do you think you're like the way
that you are because you know most
people aren't like that
like what do you mean like
wow
were you born like that i think so what
were you like as a kid
i would i would laugh a lot i wasn't
really yelling swiggy as a little kid i
didn't get the name swiggy that i was in
like middle school like people started
calling me as my last name is pearl swig
but like yeah i'd always had the crazy
laugh though that's that's always you
always had a lot of that when you were
little what you laughed like that when
you were little yeah that's terrifying
it might be a little different it's
gonna go through puberty the vocal
chords change a little bit differently
yes
uh
kinda not really i don't know how old
were you when you started doing drugs uh
like
like high school only like ninth grade
something like probably 15.
yeah it's pretty normal put them under a
microscope
why are you the way you are yeah
i don't know what could it be no like
yeah like are your siblings like this
too yeah i remember like the high school
i dropped a lot of mushrooms i didn't
really start dropping acid there until
like maybe like oh a year after i
graduated i remember i wanted to but for
every reason i didn't know where to get
it you know i feel like shrooms is way
more hardcore than lsd
yeah i don't know like i asked more i
don't know i think it's i think my is
way more hardcore than mushrooms i agree
yeah yeah but i like both but mushrooms
a little more damn you also got this
i smoked some on uh thanksgiving that
was pretty cool dude i saw like these
like these patterns and like they went
like into my
when you were little you were like titty
like when you were
you were breastfeeding my dad is like a
hippie he did like a lot of like
swinging when he started drinking
you sound like you're about to spit
everywhere every time you
[ __ ]
my dad's kind of a crazy dude he's got
like this like electric man thing where
he like walks around like a one-man band
at like the philadelphia folk festival
he's got like an amplifier and like a
peter frampton voice box that's awesome
yeah it's pretty wacky he's an artist as
like you are yeah performer yeah i have
an idea i wouldn't do this thing called
projector man i get like an all-white
suit kind of like uh the green man and
solely sonic like uh kkk
yeah well i mean it's like it's like
white so
different people as mike's like go up as
like swiggy then go up as projector man
like
that would be pretty funny
did everyone the kkk
didn't even say goodbye that's sad i was
just mean to him the whole time and then
he left
i get really frustrated with them
sometimes because like he goes up there
and he's like i'm the best comedian oh
why did you react like that oh that's
fine that's
funny that you did that
and then he like does crowd work and he
never does material
like i haven't really seen him do
the one that was sitting here that i got
mad at
the one that's spilled
the zionist guy right wait he doesn't
have a car where'd he go
really
he's gonna do carpool here he's got a
thumb dude
he was listening the whole time oh [ __ ]
he's over there i'm just kidding
he's just in the bathroom i was like
[ __ ] you guys still here
he's listening to the podcast yeah
listening on his bike home he's like
dude i was just [ __ ] clapping for you
guys
literally turn around
was mario supposed to come no
hey guys
it's pretty much uh mario is michael
malamud
same type of person just with
more showering
um but yeah i mean uh that was a fun mic
uh ridge's mic had a nice audience and
then they all left by the time
the kimchi mic started like 20 people
yeah that's good
yeah true foods i signed up for ridge's
mic and the [ __ ]
uh
website wouldn't send me a goddamn
confirmation email there so you were
pending you were already i was pending
the whole time i kept saying resend
recent i thought i had a virus that kept
telling me to check my spam folder i was
like
maybe i'm the problem you know i'm not
even good at that technology stuff like
signing up for those mics like i just
show up i usually say i'm like you like
said like the names i was like how do
you know how to like check that [ __ ] i
was like dude like
yeah that's why i have the show go up
which is annoying because like people
have to drive to the domain so some
people want like a guaranteed spot
before they go
so this is it's nice for some people but
i just think that it's [ __ ] up when
you're like everyone's signing up
beforehand and then it's just like yeah
uh
i don't know it's just it rewards people
who like just sign up or whatever who
like wake up at a certain time i dig
your approach to not just that but like
the randomizing of it too like i think
it's democratized
for sure like you see a lot of stress
out for sure hell yeah you see a lot of
people just like like
clicked up in front who were like like
used to that mic and they're like oh
[ __ ] i'm the first 15 and you're like
all right and then it's like
yeah you do the randomizing factor which
is cool because it makes everyone then
you don't
rewarding people for wasting more time
for sure oh yeah i know you showed up
two hours early what a g what a genius
yeah
you got the best slot
but i like the uh internet signups for
for most most of the time
you go down you gotta go like lucky duck
or like tiniest bar four hours early
it's it's not fun
lucky duck is the worst cause then they
bump everyone yeah
i was hanging out with another today
right
okay what are you all doing yeah i was
hanging out with the autumn as i live
with mike dragon you just came over
there
yeah they're actually talking about that
too he's talking about he just bumps
people up
yeah miles johnson calls him the prince
of darkness
he's like
um how was moon tower
it was cool man were you there yeah it
was i think i went a couple of mikes
after you yeah yeah yeah i think i did
see there too i i was uh
it was loud right there was like a whole
group to the right of these like
every comic was roasted on these chicks
so it was like a 21st birthday or
something but they were
louder than
the microphone and
you know it's a tough mic when you
can't like there was laughs but it was
like they were ruining it and then
there's volleyball it was a lot going on
man
oh on the tv no there was people playing
volleyball you could just hear it
the host mentioned it to me yeah
there's like a whole ass game going on
and then there's like
i don't know i mean it was a cool mic uh
i love it
just there's a lot going on so you got
to be focused i i don't think i can i
don't think i did i don't think i bombed
but uh definitely no one heard [ __ ] so
yeah it was it was [ __ ] awesome i
would definitely go there like every
[ __ ] week though it's just like so
different because it's like not only
not only do you have
a [ __ ] great [ __ ] stage to perform
on but
it's just like the whole [ __ ]
audience it's like no comics it's just
like a [ __ ] table in the corner of
those comments
only tough thing about today like you
said was just like the [ __ ]
like group of loyals are like [ __ ] 50
[ __ ] old chicks or something [ __ ]
it's like a 21st birthday or something
yeah
like that man
it was a yeah great venue though cool
mike though
run it
nick d
i don't know his last name nick d
something uh sorry buddy appreciate you
man
no he was cool cool people man i
appreciate it i'll see you
see you again i want to sign up again
dude you got me
confused puja yeah
so who wants to play katan
oh are we playing
who wants to play katan yeah i'll play
okay
i don't know how to play but i mean
me uh who else wants to play
i'll play
[ __ ] you're playing
are you playing i can play business like
four players or some [ __ ] it's six
okay you want to play sure
you want to play do you want to play
yeah i think i can keep up with these
dumbasses
you don't want to play do you want to
play i can't yeah
okay
how many is that too many seven
swing
or we could just keep talking
yeah i don't even know how to play but
you know try to figure it out
why don't we just play four player with
the people that know how to play like me
you
michael malamud and then who else knows
how to play i know how to play but
someone else does you can go it's you
buddy it's all you man i'm like a 30
knowledgeable i'm just
i've never even heard of it not gonna
lie to like today i'm just being honest
yeah you guys can watch this
dude
[ __ ] reminds me of some rick and
morty [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] is it like let's get
let's get let's get schwifty
what's the little cat guy you got you
guys want a schwanz or something
watch launch
hey mind if i swap into the bathroom
he's like
and then the
the wife the beth character is like oh i
can do i can use that word i squanch my
family and they're like oh gross
all right i'm gonna scorch out boys
squatch chris all right brother later
bro
he always leaves early
that's early in the last podcast too
i'm just tired
yeah perfect can you pass me this under
the table
dude i love this game so much
okay uh
uh
how do i make this work
forest levy says no dude they're for
sure in his van
chris young did you hook up that dude
with some shrooms he gave me his email
i'm not scared to hook him up
let's just play the six player one
whoever wants to play the play it's
having conversations with themselves
yeah
who's got a good jail story while he
opens up i was little the guy one guy
says hey hans
why is the blonde guy
next to the computer reading books in a
medieval
monastery
what does that even mean yeah i don't
even know that many times they swing and
sometimes
what blonde guy this guy oh this is next
to the microphone or next to the
computer monastery
you look like uh that guy from uh
entropic thunder when they did that fake
monastery movie where they're like five
cent father and they're like being gay
robert
toby mcguire
and robert
they look like robert downey jr yeah
you guys are sharing beads and stuff
yeah
logan wanted to tell me that you left
this large
treat in his car
yeah i got it at the gas station with
him
did he leave banana bread
he
he didn't want to be on the podcast
uh
so michael have you ever had anal sex
before
because it didn't sound like you did
giving or receiving because
if giving
or receiving no i mean you did go to
you didn't go to jewish sleep-away camp
yeah that's probably the closest i came
what's the closest you've come
uh i've put my dick in a girl's butthole
once
it's really close
pretty close
[Music]
so did victor leave too
yeah he left a while ago oh [ __ ]
he's probably
crashing diabetically he's probably
cheating on his baby mama
hans and rahul were practicing sex with
the same girl just using different holes
nice
because uh
he had sex before and i had anal sex
hans this board is huge
six players this is not this big is this
like a an asian thing or six players
usually our boards are flat and small
our broads
who was making the flat asian girl that
was bert yeah he made the yeah asians
were
all flat
earth i love it asians just they just
goes for self-deprecating right away
someone asked if this is a new age ouija
board
yeah
that's smiling that's crazy about ouija
board because you're like it's an eight
and over board game
so you're like
at eight years old you could summon the
devil but you can't [ __ ]
smoke cigarettes it doesn't make sense
this is some alabama logic
i'm so ready to have more of this
conversation when we get off this
podcast
stories of larry potter
john weasley and harry potter play
summon
are you from greensboro alabama
[Music]
no dude [ __ ] no dude that's forrest
gump yeah yeah it's
a town that's known to make retards man
yeah dude
some of the finest retards as country
has ever seen
and
[Music]
you want to [ __ ] with the tiniest
yo asian men aren't that weak china
isn't even letting in girly
men things anymore
because it's getting harder to
distinguish that [ __ ] you know
yeah you gotta weed out the gene pool
um yeah i mean
i heard they stopped killing women
babies
really i heard that they're called baby
girls
baby women all the way
it's not because they realize they
[ __ ] up and they they just have like
way too many dudes now they basically
need to [ __ ]
salvage all the [ __ ]
uh female population
yeah
that's the wrong way to do it you need
one man and five women and then they can
pregnant them all when you say salvage
they make make them into soup
because they cook babies in the soup
there sure
that's uh
what
they got
is that
you guys
i might be white but i'm not stupid all
right
[Laughter]
it's a real thing they have so many
abortions there of uh of the like ladies
that they make so tell them
does it taste good
sure i kind of want it
oh china does
that's what that's worse than something
dog suit man
all right dog soup bad soup and
female baby soup
dog and female tied for first male mood
yeah i met a dude who was like uh
he's in the marines and he said he was
stationed in cambodia and he said
they're eating dog and he said he ate
some just because he was like hungry and
it's like what they're eating he said it
was it was alright he said it was kind
of good
he said he was surprised like he thought
it was gonna be like groceries
i was in south korea once and they they
had uh dog cafes like this is true no no
[ __ ]
you [ __ ]
you pick your dog out and you [ __ ]
they cook it for you dude
it's like it's like a hug
it's like a petting you're like oh i got
dog soup and pet some dogs and it's like
nah dude it's like
i have to cook that [ __ ]
are you making that up i swear i'm not
this is south korea i was in busan south
korea
dude i'm not joking this is a real thing
google it [ __ ] look it up dude i'm
telling you it's a real thing
fact check me google check me
i believe you
we probably do that
yeah i mean it's really convenient in
some ways and really horrific in other
ways it's like oh i think i'm gonna go
eat some soup and pet my dog and it's
like
no
choice you're not gonna pet it you're
gonna pick it and then you're gonna eat
yours that's what you're gonna do
the petting is in your belly
oh i see you tenderizing the meat
can i figure out a way to sit down is
there another chair or something dude
there's no chair nearby there's like a
score of pillows though
i think i could stack up some pillows i
think you should stack up some pillows
dude
do you care if i stack up pillows go
knock yourself out michael thank you i
think you should flip that trash can
over upside down that'll be a nice seat
for you what is it made out of
uh
[Music]
so let's uh go around and roll and see
who goes first you first pat
just put the box just leave the box down
seven
of the box over here
[Music]
i guess
[Music]
is it cantonese
no you're not playing sound i didn't
think so you
should sit on my lap he'd be much more
comfortable
yeah i don't think any of this scenario
should have been this way
i mean just keep an open mind and you
know play the game you know
it's a board game
mine's open enough man
i'm uh
i i regret sitting on these pillows like
it didn't do this is like sitting on the
floor you did not grab enough pillows i
want you to know are there other pillows
i mean like grab a couch cushion i don't
think of cushions as pillows that's my
problem
just
like no maybe in alabama okay you know
y'all sit on
cushions well try again
[Music]
maybe in alabama
[Laughter]
sit on your cousins
that's right but in texas we sit on
cushions
and men well
so oh is it my turn
so are you the highest number
yeah oh no that's a recycling you can
just put it on the counter i'll take
care of it later
i'm
gay comedy praise a lot i love jewish
people by jesse excellent work jesse we
love you
that's one of our true fans
i'll bet
we fully endorse
that weird mix of anti-semitism and
islamophobia but pro-gay
stuff
yeah not homophobic definitely not
homophobic
he just hates people who hates gay
people
which is the most progressive thing you
could do
i think i was reading about that in time
cosmopolitan man
and i got to fix this i'm sorry
thank you i am complete
i'm ready
to watch
i'm getting some of these cushions
yeah i'm going to show you telling me
dude
that's how we do in alabama i think he's
nesting
he's creating a jew lair
there you go dude
these things are true i would put those
on the bottom yeah these things are too
long
this is not an apartment
says i request a roast battle while
playing katan person rolling the dice
gets roasted
dies
but yeah that's a good idea i think
someone also just said comedy
so who needs a primer on how to play
uh so you just uh the number of dots is
how probable it is so the red ones are
the most probable
three dots not that probable two it
doesn't get rolled a lot but this gets
rolled a lot
and so you want to pick a vertex that
has a lot of dots on it the more dots
the better
that's what we say in india too
the more dots the better
and oh my god that's how we say it why
is
japanese or something
that's pretty big
bigger than mine
let's go this way
all right now it's pat's turn
let me raise it up
the parents stay in the apartment we're
in the van right now
i saw that too don't don't wake up the
parents is that what you're responding
to yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's scary
like trying to do this while the parents
are sleeping yeah
don't worry about that we're too chicken
but full but full
but hey but
i can't cast on spotify
it's pretty close man it's almost there
this is audio only for those tuning in
yeah hey
hans you want to tilt your camera down a
little bit thanks man yes sir
is that the garbage can yeah
yeah that's where it is right there oh
yeah give me that yeah right there right
there right there perfect actually yeah
yeah you went up a little bit just good
enough
come back over and see what you think
dude let's see if we're looking at it
right now oh you can see it on the thing
yeah what do you think i should go down
more well it depends on where you're at
in frame
i think it looks fine
oh is it my turn to put down a
settlement
you're trying to get roasted wait who oh
[ __ ] i didn't even realize the way it
was hans and then you went
oh [ __ ] it's my turn now it looks like
monopoly there's like little houses
so it's hans bert
no
hat i'll tell you i don't remember your
name
rahul okay
me
and then tim washbomb or whatever tommy
tommy
tommy
teddy
yeah everyone's like focus on me now
there we are
you can tell pick a good one roast me
baby you look like vera dust yo someone
just roasted you so hard on the chat
me yeah what does it say it says uh what
did it say
can i hear all this
center frame perfect
and they said that you're three months
pregnant or something right effie
i don't know i think that's pad oh maybe
it's like curly hair you both got curly
hair so you could either
is that on your neck
the real show is on [ __ ] chat is
roasting
you know a lot about the internet for
someone who just got it six months ago
spectrum hooked me up dude
oh
man the thing i love about this game is
that it's hard from the beginning
that's what she said
sure
i noticed there's no pink houses is that
something against melon camp or
just
gays in general what's what's going on
with your game here on gays in general
because we don't have pink houses
um
yeah i mean
is that like stress relief on your
spine guns yeah
i have a herniated disc
little fluid leaks out and presses on a
nerve and then this way i don't have my
head sitting on
top of that where you get the
does it like stretch your neck out like
those african things yeah that's what
that's lots of [ __ ] things
okay
this is like that but modern times
with technology
we can beat the african women
i'm going for the record
yeah it's got to be commitment do
something like stretch your neck out i
don't think it goes back to normal after
you stretch it you know
you're thinking of something else yeah
that michael is your turn
now you're moving faster
i don't think i am i don't even i don't
understand how this game is on my team
all right
this is how it works
but i could take
parts of that but now i feel like i'd be
cheating because you gave me a hint oh
you better that's his fault he's [ __ ]
up
wait are you going before me no no
that's me yeah all right what color are
you um
i'm green
you need a menu okay that's not bad
uh sure what's your you're making me so
hungry huh i'm white
you want to eat me
do you don't need one right
if you are in texas you like the ed gin
[ __ ] yeah
oh so
you already went right what
ed gene is he's like from texas dude the
chat texas chainsaw guy yeah the movie's
based on leather
he's not really yeah well the real dude
that was a real dude yeah it was loosely
based off this dude game but like the
movie is like a lot different
like very loosely very loosely yeah yeah
yeah yeah a lot of [ __ ] like most of the
[ __ ] he did he like dug up already dead
bodies yeah yeah
the movies like murdering people with a
chainsaw he was just like
he's actually kind of a good guy
he took up already dead bodies
you just wanted to make love to this
bomb after she died you know it's
completely normal
who can blame it
i heard it was in her will he was
allowed to or something
he was required to he didn't have a
choice
[Music]
oh damn
what happens are you allowed to put [ __ ]
like that in your will you know what i
mean like i don't think so
i hope so let necrophiliacs use my body
my husband's into dead chicks and when i
did not go with it
i give him permission
chad is allowed to [ __ ] poke me sure
sure give him two days and then he's
interesting
so you pick up your resources from your
second settlement
hmm
we got two rocks and a brick swinging
two racks and a brick
yeah
try not to show people
hmm you gotta poke your face try not to
tell us as well
i mean you can look and see what my
second settlement was
it's been a while so just so i'm not
cheating i get one of those one of those
one of those right because i put this
down second yeah yeah okay
all right
yeah fix your house yeah tornado my
house is gonna be
this is jordan peterson you got to clean
your room
that's how to fix all the problems in
the world
let the games
begin
shape
would
wait it's kind of like risk it's like
just take over everything yeah
yeah i laughed so hard playing risk once
nine
so there's a nine here orange gets a
sheep and there
there's a nine there
that's it there's two nines over there
oh there's a nine over there
real close
they're in there
those are
those are called bed bugs dude those
aren't sheep i don't know what you guys
are talking about you guys are [ __ ]
blind dude i got so many tiny sheep in
my bed right three
you said it so passionately
is that a rocket
you can't put it there you can nope
why not
because it's fine yeah yeah and then you
get to steal from someone
i will let's see what do you guys have
rocks i start rhyming and stealing
you don't have [ __ ] there
nope it's
i got i don't know i thought you were
like fanning them out for me or
something
uh i'll take it from you because you
took my
oh you're taking one of my ideal spots
no dude
best possible outcome
it's a ghost
hans paid half of the bill
this month
is the camera out too oh yeah it looks
like i plugged it over there
oops
what a mistake
you're welcome
turns out michael made another
comedy is an art form and i am an artist
yeah you keep saying that and then you
never do the comedy part
i yeah
that's false
that's false come on that's true
thank you
whose turn is it
ron
you got a run
seven
oh you got to move the little guy yeah
yeah yeah all right
i don't want it do i no
[Music]
he's still from pat or me
uh yeah let me see what you got hans
i'll take the middle of that
the cameron the cameron
cameron look at the camera the camera
but all the same dudes
and are you gonna buy anything
no i'm good
okay it's your turn michael
thank you for reminding me
let's get like uh
i don't know
onto the box please oh is that the thing
let's get him
yeah i don't roll into the board oh two
oh nice hmm
nut sack a solid
ball ball
what is it two of two
is that where you call it where you're
from we call it snake eyes oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so we love here in alabama
yeah we see it appreciation of the mail
form but specifically that part of the
mail form yeah
i appreciate it are you gonna buy
anything michael
um
absolutely
if someone
has a brick i don't think anyone has a
brick yet yeah what do you have to offer
yeah really i do
oh baby i got
i got some hay
i got a sheep oh baby
[Applause]
in 70 degree december in austin you can
make like a blanket you want some sheep
i'm good
kill it and eat it you want uh hay
or both you want hay and sheep
why do people [ __ ] sheep that's like a
thing you don't really hear people
they're there
they're so [ __ ] sexy
they're soft
they're warm they all feel good let's do
it here
yeah yeah yeah let's do it oh yeah
let's build a road wait you want to do a
lower yeah
[ __ ] talking about my snake guys
[Laughter]
where is the uh bank so to speak is that
this
the bank is these
you just put them back in the pile
cool
oh that's anticlimactic it's right on
top huh you can put them on the bottom
but
slightly anti-semitic
that's it
you can't say anti with the other hand
you're so protective
also where are you building towards
god only knows hans i'm barely paying
attention
but i will rock baby all right
because you'd have to go all the way
over here to build a settlement i just
wanted to build something
you know confidence before knowledge
sometimes
i'm gonna acknowledge someone from the
chat earlier they said they would not
trust white tea around their sister i
don't know why i give that vibe off like
four
i think it's a beautiful white t-shirt
thanks
i said i would not trust white tea
around my sister she got that beautiful
smile
you know how to have fun and feel good
about yourself oh thanks hans hell yeah
dude and you know how to make women feel
good mice on the inside oh wait wait
what
the limp biscuit you know they just came
out like a new album it's called limp
biscuit it still sucks
let's not get political
i don't even know they're slower it's
pretty well
it
[Music]
we got so many rocks
don't don't stop putting that
yeah
you put it down
didn't stop believing oh three someone
said three yeah it was three i don't
know that he rolled you good
trace
more like
[ __ ]
ravioli
before
all right
i can do some [ __ ] now oh i got two
fours wait what are we supposed to roast
the person that's rolling the dice
that's something we ignored a long time
ago
we're still playing he just hasn't been
able to think of anything he's been
trying to first
roll you guys are all so nice i don't
want to be me
all right let's put this [ __ ] down
hell yeah go places roads
all right sorry
three again he looks exactly like the
green goblin
who's red spider-man you got three
and are you building anything
then pass the dice
sachet away
to uh nope
oh yeah right next to you
hey
nice dude okay that roll
that's how you're getting laid tonight
dude i'm telling you you're not even
close i'm not even trying it's in the
cards did we not talk about this
i'm not trying to get laid
he's trying to build trying to [ __ ]
pillage i gotta build right
now man not rape you can start legend
anyone got um
i play my rape cards
[Laughter]
yeah
they're good man
what color are they white
they're not rolled very well yeah
i think it's pretty hot
any young brick sellers looking to move
up
no dude with some hay
just
what else would i pay would i take for
hay
you mean you're offering me something
i'm asking what you would take for
height oh what i would take for hay
uh oh i would take
and i would take sheep
would you take a virginity too i would
take six virginities i would do sheep
for for hey
wait and we'll wait would you do
something i would do she performed
you usually need like virgin lamb's
blood
i think the real question is how much
you would pay for a check coming down
the street saying hey hey hey
that was the that was what you've been
thinking of this whole time yeah
all the sheep talk is really exciting
but okay your turn
you know real quick yeah
testicles
yeah dudes okay
sounds like it is
are you done
eight
[ __ ] yeah
person who has a beacon yeah
both of us yeah you got a junior's
whiter whiter browns
thanks well we'll get back to it
we'll see yeah we'll see yeah
hans gave clear instructions don't
talking about the jew which jew there
are so many here
i get defensive oh you got my appearance
you're not supposed to acknowledge it
yeah
well what do i get though
you're just proving them right me no i
get stuck
i got fives next to my curious as if
they're on what you're green you got a
two fives right here yeah yeah so get
the sheep uh-huh just one nope two
[Music]
oh my god
more than you can handle
sound like that
no no you gotta be able to do it
just pick up another sheep you and your
bed and pick up a rock too while you're
at it because a lot of twos have been
rolled
that's it that's all you get well that
would have been his second settlement
right so he would have gotten that by
default oh [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] up man i handicapped
myself yeah
that happens are you feeling empty so
did he
i need the bricks
okay well if you can't do anything then
just pass the dies
on to this sounds like some someone in
the hood let's say that i need to be
rude
yo man where are my bricks at yo i need
those bricks
you acting like you don't have my praise
six baby yes all right
god damn we need to move that robber
dude
that's two sexes now
we can hop over there in the mountains
would you rather have a ten or two sixes
anybody have stone
and want to trade for
hay
i got hay
hey anybody want to trade for wood stone
for wood wood is great
keep saying they say there's a freezer
coming i love wood you know i've got one
yeah
i don't need it you want my rope you
want it
yeah please i'll give you something cool
and
i buy a development card please
is that them yep okay
then
you can only play it on your next turn
yeah and um your turn has ended oh
really just from buying probably no you
only have two cards you can't buy
anything oh dude you could buy a road
he could trade oh he could use his
[ __ ] thingy does anybody have brick
though
seriously
if anyone if anyone's got prick i'm just
in conversation about brick right now
well you know you know what they are at
jews right
that they love brick yeah we do love
bricks a little bit
yeah
[Music]
it's good for like doing like a crystal
knock to get the bricks then you can
like break the glass
and it's so hard
[Music]
i don't even know what that is oh you
don't i mean i know what big bang theory
is
the jewish character he lives with his
mom and his mom's always like yelling at
him no but i think my mom thinks i'm
like the dude with asperger's on it she
like loves him a lot we also feel
similar to the indian character
yeah
he's indian so therefore i'm
automatically the same
yeah i'm a virgin too i don't i can only
talk
alcohol you're just way sadder than that
guy yeah you're a really sad indian
yeah aren't we all though
you're like a native american how sad
you are
[Music]
the saddest of indians i'm done
yeah
oh chris young said these guys work at
verizon [ __ ] two
oh
that's a two i get it
i wish we're getting [ __ ] yeah
way was that a
castle hell yeah millie 2315
thank you
what did millie said i'm cool ah yeah
sitting on the pillows is that your mom
my mom is molly that's why you're doing
so well in the podcast
i'm so proud of you
you've made it oh y'all
hey
victor martinez inflated himself like a
balloon
uh i'm gonna play my robber
nice
yeah
who put that there by the way that
really [ __ ] me
yeah someone needs to roll a seven
because that guy has like eight cards
hm
oh [ __ ] with that rule
if you have more than seven cards you
lose half your cards on when a seven is
rolled so you're incentivized to spend
your cards hmm
interesting
i didn't know that this guy's got seven
sheets
i'm having a
party i'm dangerous all right
oh man eleven
eleven
nice
you know what we call that was that wood
ten to there
does anyone want wood for
wheat
yeah yeah sure
all right you're you're giving me
no i i want you ask me for my wood no i
i i'm sorry
i want i want wood oh oh no only was
that easy at the bar
does anybody ladies want you would for
some wheat
gladly trade
the wood for some sheep
all right
you lost that that was a good sheep too
i got
that's you more
homie on the pillows isn't a horrible
dude or anything just needs to relax and
vibe
never
never he's so anxious all the time
someone said i'm high like my natural
smoked wheat
what would you call it now joseph this
is a
sausage fest
when i was younger i'd call this a
sausage fest who's next now he calls it
a party
now he's like hey
noise
oh who rolled the seven nozzle
ah what a fun game
why don't you tell us this crazy story
another great story let's go dude all
right hell yeah dude on the pillows is
cool ladies [ __ ] look him up you just
got a [ __ ] seven minutes wake up to
it
[Laughter]
he'll do it
oh
yeah
what a bummer
um
i don't like but i don't still get to
take i don't know
i thought he was cool
just
from him or him
okay oh yeah yeah cause i'm wearing my
dick
uh yeah yeah just a little bit you just
took five of my cards
i did not
like your life your poor management
exactly
these things happen
that sucks man
does anyone
no
word
okay so if not that stop [ __ ] my [ __ ]
okay
what more do you want from me
you can only do so much
this isn't enough i just appreciate the
effort what more do you have
lose half your cards they make
like you're six is that an eight you
think it's an eight oh it's a six [ __ ]
there's three sixes
three eights okay that makes sense if
you're using lame skinned condoms it's
kind of like banging a sheep
here it is like that
i just thought that was weird like he
was like let's take the skin of the lamb
and like put it around my dick
no no i killed the sheep first and
skinned it and then i [ __ ] it it's
cool it's like i'm [ __ ] my wife but
i'm actually [ __ ] my favorite sheep
[Laughter]
does anyone have stone shoes
that they want to give away yeah i want
to get rid of these two sheep i like
this one it pushes back hard
all right well i'll take some weak ones
because i you know i'm not very picky uh
hey do you like hey yeah i like hey
you're so kind yeah yeah that's what i
said all right yeah it's nice to do
business this guy right here is my
favorite for sure yeah do you have a
name well does anyone have stone and one
i don't want to get to it don't tell us
don't tell you someone
someone might take it from me
i'm just trying to keep it casual then
you and
baja
i don't care why anyone's interrupting
my turn right now does anyone have stone
i have lots of stone you can have none
of it are you serious
all right i'm done with my turn
because it's ruining their sick jokes
there's a thing where you can put on the
stream that they can't spam that's a
that's a real thing
i didn't know about that why don't you
just spam your sick jokes
i had some dude come up to me at the
kill tony after party and asked me if i
had people spamming swiggy on the chats
and i was like dude i don't i don't have
anything nothing i didn't even know
about it used to be that's a swiggy army
[Laughter]
are you done
yeah if no one straight
would you even roll
doesn't matter no three three
five
i got five
got fives on five's on five
oh yeah fresh sheep
okay come here baby do i get do i get
four
are these sweet little babies or two all
right oh you got one two three three all
right anyone have
wood and want wheat
yeah
how much
was just one for one yeah hey squeaky
that guy loves you yeah yeah another one
yeah yeah because swiggy if you read
this brother just know i love you keep
being you dude yeah man i love you too
but like no homo i love you kind of like
how like a father loves a son you know
[Music]
emphasis on the no mode
white t-shirt dude what's your twitter
and where can you find your stand up oh
man yo i'm sam kuiper i don't got a
twitter but you can find me on ig i'm
actually getting shirts made for sale or
say swiggy white's barbecue it's got
like the same logo as terry black's
yeah hit me up on uh
jim swiggy is my instagram hit me up on
there if you want
is that legal
uh
i don't know man it's uh slightly
different so i mean i don't know but i'm
only getting 24 of them made so if you
want one and they get sold out i mean i
don't know maybe i'll make more if like
looks like people buy them
i'll take one dude yeah people in my
work want them dude my manager came up
because i was telling people my work is
like i heard you're making shirts to
look like our shirts but it says swiggy
white so i wasn't getting trouble he's
like put me down for a large
start crocheting
blankets off
does anyone have a rock they'd like to
trade
i have food
thank you
there's no chat in here
spelled
r k-i-p-e-r yeah there we go oh yeah
oh thanks hans appreciate that
moving on up correcting
you're gonna
[Music]
soothe people with your
alabama
and their sisters down home country
wisdom oh yeah should have your own
podcast
six
yeah it's a
i got in the studio for it to be honest
but
yeah i tried doing one this past monday
it was astonishing it's kind of shitty
with amy oh yeah music
what did you do and she seems like
really uh wild and really yeah she she
is pretty
she was
like insulting your podcast yeah she was
yeah she was definitely talking [ __ ] on
and on it was pretty odd and then before
she left like after we'd on filming it
she asked me and logan like double team
really then she just left i was like
okay okay
that's on the internet now
she's cool with that
she's like she want to double i'll just
get out of here never mind
yeah
i just oh she said it was she just a
rain check i didn't even notice like
logan because she like whispered it or
something and then she like rolled off
then logan's like did you miss that and
then you told me that i was like what
like oh that's that's crazy did she
finish she's all made up
we're doing it
are you uh this is cool i went it's
ron's turn
people got cities over here i'm not
doing [ __ ]
ron barely had two settlements
a religion
what'd you wrote
thanks borak
swiggy is actually a neurological
diagnosis
good one
always told them there's something wrong
with them
maybe i was in special ed class for math
growing up
that's true
was it like
3 through 12 or was it no it's probably
like six through seven yeah they're
probably like fifth or sixth grade on
you know grew out of it that's a wrong
way you're good
it's the opposite
it didn't go
all away i'm good
yo it is not a brick market right now i
don't know if you all realize
brick city it's a sheep you need a brick
dude yeah
you are a full eight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo massive shout out to the stone posse
yeah someone just said she's a freak
great timing take the mic away for a
swig
best austin food truck nearby vulcan gas
company shawarma halal on 8th and red
river
amazing
is that the one that's down here that
hoboken pie it's right near stubs it's
across the street from stubs barbecue
is that better than the wall time whose
turn is it
not mine are you done it's between both
of those i i am done i said it all right
i haven't tried that pass the dies
michael
sorry
you guys are a cute couple
that was swiggy tommy pod eleven
[Music]
give ourselves another city
let's go
good for you man
you can't build cities without sheep
people you know you can
do not listen to sam it was never played
that was an alabama moment brought to
you by sam kuiper
you're good
you're good tim thompson
tommy dummy
eleven
already painted
um anyone
what about one rock without the bricks
you can't i'll give you a rock and a
sheep
rock in a shaped deal i'll give you some
lavender
what is that purple one it looks like
stay tuned
static in the void of this video someone
says
okay
all
right
past the dies
hello
it's me
i don't know
someone just says
liars dude we did it
trolls
they just wanted to see me put the
headphones on they're like oh it is
really live
i'm done
oh
that's the only people ron [ __ ] is
with four flaps
so like a vagina
it's like another vagina
please tell us more about vaginas
[Laughter]
i gotta buy a house at some point
okay
nine nine
you won't move to the what do i do when
i pay whatever
that's the steady crack can i just put
this somewhere anywhere you gotta buy a
road first oh road okay
i'll help you i can try to be
your extension of arm
you build roads whiskey
yeah yeah
you haven't but
people do
okay the rectangles are right
man there are people doing serious work
out here and i'm sitting here with my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
look at that
you and your rocks you built one road
this whole game yeah i got some cards
though can you connect to like other
people's towns and stuff
yeah it doesn't really do anything
dude hell yeah dude
michael how is anal what are you going
to do ron oh can i buy a road then i
thought it was my chance all right so i
got to pay those back and then put this
over there somewhere
set me up dude get out there
you want to build a road
i would say build find out for yourself
four
six eight this is five
nine i'd say this is slightly more
valuable unless you really want more
i sheep actually but not school does he
need this too did you have enough
resources to buy all that uh i it said a
road was uh a brick and mortar wood yeah
and then did you have did you buy the
settlement as well
no i uh no i didn't have enough because
i only yeah i only had the one bridge
you don't just get a settlement lick
this bias
you handed it to me
all right so now we're now we're good
i love how analytical people are it's
like whoever has the second head
handheld mic is rubbing up on it or
maybe the cord yeah
that mic is really sensitive
so just um put it down until
it's everything else man it's gonna be
better once you let go dude it's feeling
like i gotta hit hans am i crazy he's
winning oh you're all this
[Laughter]
wait a minute
oh
boy
no but that's like that would be sad
yeah pick on ron yeah
in a different timeline
all right
stone brick stone brick i got so much
stuff y'all i got sheeps i got haze for
days i got wood for
good
anyone there's like some rubbing sound
coming from one of the lights
still
you want to
man the headphones
sure
anyone want water
sure yeah yeah i want a cigarette
one two three
i'm chilling
like that okay there's a patio out there
yeah yeah i might dip and come back with
a smooth suit yeah i'm going to do that
with you
is that cool whose turn is it uh it's
well i'm at the end of mine stone and
brick no one right i'm right so now i
don't seem like
yeah it's time for us
yeah right now
so you want so no one has break for him
maybe we shouldn't maybe people are
actually enjoying anyone with scissors
they want you to take something
yeah it says it takes scissor anyone
wants scissors
[Music]
the destroyer
[Music]
says that
is it does it say shiva the destroyer
they didn't even
this is like asmr yeah this is asmr get
the mic in there they're saying the uh
sound is better
oh yeah listen to that
probably gave like 20 dudes orgasms oh
yeah
i came i'm [ __ ]
take 10 cigarette breaks
or not yeah that was your chance
sounds good right now take a scissor bro
break scissors
that wasn't even funny you want to play
for michael yeah
it's not like do something interesting
is it still your turn i will [ __ ] your
sheep finished that's right
yes you may thank you can i have a glass
of water yes you are okay thank you
one for you i'll do this okay
you don't need one run no i gotta lose
weight so these [ __ ] stop talking
about my belly with no water
[Music]
i gotta figure out these calories
oh yeah the oreos
that's how they work
they're nice
[Music]
uh i will take an oreo
and you're fine you're aiming in you're
not in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah because it hasn't had a fat guy
say it again
[Laughter]
are you picking up michael malamud's
orange
temporarily
is it my turn to roll no no i didn't
think so
would you be wrong
does anybody have a sheep
i do
mine are way cuter we need and they're
well trained by at this point what i
need uh no not wood stones yeah i need
wood i'll take his tongue
what do you have for wood
i need wood
sheep
yeah i'll take a brick i'll give you a
wood
how did you build a settlement
it's down sheep wheat and
the brick
it's wood
you don't need a stone for a settlement
sorry wood sheep wheat brick oh yeah i
thought you were buying a development
card because you put down a rock
you're gonna put down a rock
no i put down brick okay
are you done yes
eight
once break
yeah anything you want
i'll give you my best sheet
ross
rock and wheat oh no i thought you
wanted wood yeah i got rock and wheat
thanks
you're actually not supposed to do that
you want another brick
yeah yeah you have wood yeah i stopped
training with hans
okay
cool now i can finally do stuff thanks
nice
hell yeah dude
don't look at the good cards
that's the only guy that i sleep apnea
when he laughs
yeah that's for sure
does anybody want to trade sheep for
sheep this one keeps biting my heels
the dad jokes
was a bit late
is it too late
you didn't pick up four did you
it's two this time two a little bit
earlier no was there two sixes
no
um
[Music]
let's see
i want a
sheep if anyone has sheep
i could give
wood
rock yeah i'll take rock
take wood
yeah i'll give you one
bad trade dude
i don't care he was gonna give me more
would you have given me two sheep yeah
his face he was trying to rip you off
he's like [ __ ] look at my star
stature you're gonna tell me no
um
i need a lot of wood
well you have plenty out here
you know with the sausage fest
all right dude
some progress here [ __ ] yeah
all right you go yeah no i'm still doing
some more [ __ ]
pause it's ron's turn and then your
return oh yeah yeah yeah right good call
good call
dyslexic that's fine
because i'm gonna be [ __ ]
it's another word you're ocd and
dyslexic it's tough life dude yeah
and from alabama
all right
let's get some
focus going on yeah
did you guys go out the front door
wouldn't just go on the patio oh yeah oh
that's what a patio is
these are for you
austinites call every spot of land that
is attached to their apartment which is
usually three square feet of patio
so i thought about the front
the front
ah the patio i'm gonna go out
the patio my front patio
the only exit
i almost walked into the apartment and i
did open the door to the apartment next
door it was dark it was pretty
embarrassing man that's horrible
those people were probably terrified i
was gonna say hey but like that's the
worst thing you could have done
it's good to know
all right i'm done i thought i'm glad
that's hilarious that you thought a uh
seven i think it was
uh perfect
the hallway was a patio whoever has all
the rocks
right don't i move that thing somewhere
right now
yeah
where do i go
three
four
five nine ten
and
so more than oh yeah
but it's your choice
dude
yeah
then you steal from tommy or
uh
michael no i can see what michael has
what do you got over the tommy
uh do you need
wheat sure sure
love it
or rock no i'll take the wheat
back to the 10 again oh okay got you
guys where's the how many do i take one
all right thank you
ah rock
sweet bag
michael's turn
wait are you done ron yeah sure yeah
did you steal
did you it yeah i got a gun
so that's blocked for me
and other people
and tommy
[ __ ] no one has brick and stone i have
stone now okay what would you like i
would like
tweet
some good old wheat please
dude
turns over
custodize
thank you dude
[Music]
friendship
[Laughter]
this is like when your controller's
unplugged and you give it to your little
brother so you could act like he's
playing
all right
remember back in the day playing 64 we'd
like gank out controllers or playing
gold knives and [ __ ]
no we used that [ __ ] too
it took me a second to think about it
totally
[Laughter]
mario party
the best game drinking casual whatever
dude mario
drinking how old were you when n64
[Laughter]
i remember playing pong and doing heroin
good old days as they used to say good
my first game
console was the sega genesis how old are
you what about you guys i'm 32. oh
you're not even that old how are you
drinking during 33.
i wasn't like when mario party came out
it wasn't again the guys
still they still work you know hans this
is
2016. that's nice look at that guys
we finally got color tv the n64 came out
it's a big year for us
playing diddy kong racing in black and
white that's great
all right i got him it was damn by the
way
let's do
trading these three in for one
wheat
nice and then that using that wheat this
wheat and three rocks
nice
let's go down the hill build your castle
man
hell yes
i put a spell on
bert does anyone have i hope so or is
that the neighbor taking revenge on
michael mallory
bert
can you lock it so michael melamud from
the other houses will come into our
house yeah i was about to ask them on
the podcast man this is [ __ ] me up
[Music]
[ __ ] it thanks so much if you open the
door they're like what are you doing
here i just
all right i'm done i think they're like
special courage or something
that's five all right
i get fresh sheep just in time fresh
you mean yeah yeah
yeah
you mean
say that's the important part
reach over there and put my road down
whereas road you should save this and
build a settlement
i don't think i can
save it for next turn okay
don't worry all right
no i don't have the wheat that's the
problem
oh what do you need just that
thank you what do you have
um i have extra sheep of course
i always get the sheep what about brick
or wood
the bricks are hard to come by and i
need to use the wood if i'm going to buy
that okay never mind i have a
prescription i'll give you a break for a
week
no no no so you need two bricks
and two wood
okay
two two three supportive
okay yeah i got to keep it there yeah i
was wondering about uh
ghost saying i'm from alabama i didn't
play no games i ate though what the [ __ ]
does that mean yeah
isn't that english
i think that was a rap
i didn't play those games
yeah it's artistic
is it uh is it me
how are yeah doing all right pat yeah
i'm doing great
what's wrong get my
[ __ ] kicked in
the moment
thank you so much
this was the minute of depression
does anyone have stone or brick
yes stoner really or stone would you
like
wood yes
420 right how many stoners oh my god
what
i really hope a seven doesn't get rolled
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
uh
about this for a second
it's good to think i like it that's so
trippy right it's like you broke
something hey
oh yeah yeah i bumped it earlier too
yeah i was like
look she's getting kicked out yeah just
got here i'm building a road
to the sea
why
save it up would it for us so i guess
you can't build a setup dude it's so
easy to say
save it up when when you're sitting on
some like property right now like you're
like just save up man save your pennies
i'm like dude you're having a you have
several estates
how easy is it to save right now are you
done or are you gonna build some more
talking
about that
yeah i am finished this is my turn's
done and i'll pass the dice too thank
you
yeah
you guys should hold hands
i love it
god damn look at this [ __ ]
jesus christ
if i got a seven i'm [ __ ] 52 card
pickup over there
if you drop your cards
what was the rule sorry too late cool
nothing
anything but a seven
eight thank god
[Laughter]
[Music]
i got rock
i feel like hans might [ __ ] finish it
or something [ __ ]
one two three four five six seven eight
seven
i mean just
whoops out some other [ __ ]
michael seems keyed the [ __ ] up yo
um
cool white tea has chronic owen wilson
what does that mean
oh it wasn't mal i don't know what that
means
wow
wow
is that what they're talking about
wow
wow well well
i think cause the other side is
this this person thinks tony
hinchcliffe's name is kill tony yeah
this makes sense
the whole show is gonna come out of bed
but we gotta wait nine
[Music]
if kill tony is watching this he is
guiltoni is not watching us
the entire show
not just
[Music]
are you decompressed now hans
this is right
yes it is
bad english from swiggy yellow
swiggy calls yeah you know it's bad
swiggy is a verb it's a noun it's a
preposition
you swing it all over me
nice
what you got right here's four nut sacks
hey we moved the thing
we moved the thing [ __ ] about time
life has never been better you know how
much we missed out
it's like when uh
afghani children have a cloudy day
they're like now the drones can't strike
us
[Laughter]
the cloud has been mommy can i go play
now tonight
it's a dark and dreary day mommy safe
sky gods
i want to go outside and burn the
american flag with all my friends
i need swingies voices my alex
sorry
bro you get some [ __ ] awesome gig
with [ __ ] amazon
turn left sweetie
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
literally any other [ __ ] alexa give
me directions to whole foods sweetie
you miss your turn
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes dude all right this should give me
the longest road [ __ ]
that's it
seven eight
and
uh see what to do here
all right that's a wheat
because i have a [ __ ] port there
this is
a sheep and i'm turning them both in
with the brick plus the wood
okay making
that that's one two three four five six
seven plus two from longest road
so that's nine
plus victory point
oh my god the ball game sneaky he won is
that it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yes nowhere wow
let's go quiet in the back i love it
a waste of time
dude you knew you won too you're like
that's why i played all that [ __ ] that's
nine did you see that nine plus this
yeah
a real professional would have done it
quick and painless
is that what your parents made you do
that's the best way to do it
so do i understand this correctly the
white comforter
yes
that is correct
that is accurate
i'm gonna
sit here and watch this
sad party of people stare at the board
while they clean it up
oh yeah let me get that bag can i take
one of these sheep home with me
it doesn't work the same
let's play another round y'all
dude
imagine
six people
be a [ __ ] fortnite of you
katan
way to make me expose myself
hell yeah dudes [ __ ] yeah
let's go boys
let's go brogan's right three hours goes
like that
it does
[Music]
simulating conversation
titty
i don't know i don't know how to help so
i'm just going to watch
you guys guys
it's making music for us
what was that do all these cards look
very good that was like the real
settlers of katan like orange blowhole
yeah i think we were just like again oh
my god dude
you never lived in a city before
what
dude i've been living in cities my whole
life and i don't know what the [ __ ] that
yeah
it's probably a train
no [ __ ] no it sounds like a ship in
like 1980. it sounds like someone's
about to start the games yeah i think
it's the purge
you didn't hear that
i heard it did it like six times all you
get is six
oh yeah who's breaking [ __ ] now
i can't believe they got bill clinton to
show up for this who's bill clinton
what was monica's lips like dude
what were all the other lips like yeah
sure dude
was it hillary better or
you know i saw a picture of hillary the
other day when she was like in her early
20s
she was a smoke show dude hippie hillary
was already [ __ ] really dude like i
was like
[ __ ] it
she was my cousin no dude if you were
just my sister would you [ __ ]
run
all right that was a cheap joke don't
make me [ __ ] don't make me take cheap
jokes dude
um
it's uh
it's like a it's like a it's funny
because i've done so many of them yeah i
hear you
i won't participate any further all
right well everybody gets one it's like
spiderman
yeah everyone gets to be spiderman once
everyone gets one
jonah hill as spiderman
if someone at work like took off to see
the new spider-man movie i was thinking
why do you have to take off work for
that you can't just like go in your
shifts
dude the same thing happens
my dude was 18 though what about was was
your person a full grown like a 30 year
old yeah
i can't believe that was a competitive
game and i didn't know it was coming you
were until then the most competitive i
was like hans is going to win he's like
coaching people what to do and then all
of a sudden this guy's like
yeah [ __ ] spitfire
dude he had nothing it was like in the
corner
quiet and deadly silent
i wish i could have known that he was
close so that i could actually enjoy the
thrill of the chase but it was just like
oh this is so boring i'm going to beat
everyone and then it's uh
like i'm this the weak link
awoke think tank someone says
all right
i guess that's what being woke is though
right it's just cause we're up at 4 a.m
oh it's
like six
[ __ ]
have to don't worry it's just a job
yeah yeah whatever oh it's only 438 i
lied to you man oh man thanks that's way
better that's better much better no it
is better you were like yeah sad you're
like an hour and 22. baby you're welcome
dude yeah i'm gonna go home and have
some hot chocolate i'll give you that
extra hour and twenty two all day thanks
man it's time to make some coffee yeah
yeah i'm gonna read something you're
ready yeah yeah
i get it
[Music]
no it's not good did you not have a car
this whole trip
i do he did but he's uh nice i think you
missed
that
i was a sober driver tonight but we're
going to re shapiro tomorrow
nice so he's driving i'm going to get
drunk [ __ ] tomorrow oh [ __ ] i'm going
too are you really yeah i'm breathing
where is he going
hell yeah it's saturday sorry sorry oh
oh you guys are going out
oh okay
i take that bat back he's actually yeah
he performed yesterday too
i saw him yesterday at uh wait yeah i
saw him yesterday at uh the vulcan he
stopped by the green room thanks
oh yeah wednesday right did he throw
food at you or no he farted
he was like
any concluding remarks
i'll i'll get the
sheep card that i stole from you back
soon hans i just i want to spend a
little more time with her
yeah your hair is sort of sheepish
yeah it's uh it helps me sneak up on
you got a little tuft of sheep
a little touch of the sheep from your
great great
ancestors someone told me i have
distinguished driver vibes i don't know
designated oh okay
i did say i was dyslexic so i mean this
isn't surprising this is alabama's
finest scholar
i am they're poet laureate i am the one
who made it out it's me and channing
tatum but
that's true he's from there anyway you
guys didn't know so the joke's not funny
i got something to say
no wait the bike's your return yeah
try and find it i will work on it i'll
figure it out sweetie what do you got to
say swinging
there we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
designated kidnap providers
thanks for coming guys all right thanks
for having me oh yeah man appreciate it
it's pretty cool